[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it in
cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
i know girls wear them big time for guys
yeah skinny jeans are out i
was like straight like for guys we ready
chin yeah
you're gonna stay with skinnies i refuse
to go baggy i know that's the trend
yeah but i'm with the bag yeah you
haven't seen it like
most celebs you won't see him in like
doesn't jay wear like bigger jeans now
too
he'll do whatever's straight yeah he
does whatever he he won't do skinny
he never he never [ __ ] with skinny no he
does like these john
he does taylor yeah but they're tailored
they're like uh
they're not a skinny fan wait he gets
them tailored
no it's like a certain tailored cut
they're not baggy
but bag no yeah it's not batteries it's
like a blue
fit that he wears but i don't know
um yeah they're like tailored they're
tapered from the
from like the calf down so he won't do
skinny though
yeah yeah he would look weird and skinny
yeah he would let's be honest though
i refuse to give in to the baggy jean
trend you're not going back to bed
never i was just talking to dilly about
this the other day i refused to get into
it
see you know what i was really into when
i was younger high water
i used to wear high water i found it as
like a jinko
jenko no i never got into jingles
because it really they were hard to
skate in
because they're shoulders they're so
baggy yeah so always have waters though
high waters yeah it was best to skating
i used to buy dickies oh and then roll
them no i never had to roll them
but they would be like like upper yeah
yeah i just haven't
those are kind of in now yeah that's
kind of kind of popping in now people
that show the socks
dog you wear sweats every day yeah right
now i ain't got no sweat today
oh there you go there you go yeah young
and reckless those are dope you got the
hat though
i got to have it back i might have some
of those for you remind me what
those those exact ones in blue and green
those pants yeah
can they fit me do you wear 38
let's be honest oh you're 40. can you
put the keys re-recording yeah because
if you have 40 i don't have that
i don't have it man got wide hips
oh you know what i peeped as your alumni
the uh your alumni
you're alumni all right east l.a oh that
that
doctor episode was pretty good we only
watched uh
we watched two episodes i'm episode six
it's good it's pretty good you said it
was awful thank you no i was
but they did one of a community college
uh football in la and is awful compared
to the original football oh god i got it
but the basketball one's legit right
coach is dope huh coach is dope he's
intense
i like that though that poor guy man
that's the hardest
because he does he'll have to coach he
has to mentor
all those idiots they're just [ __ ] up
he's the hardest job in the world
he has a mentor these morons yeah and
then he has to
because of the way the school works
since he gets full salary then he has to
teach there so he teaches a
cycling class [ __ ] multiple times a
day
then he does bible study and then he
rushes home
yeah and he stays all the way in compton
god damn oh yeah he lives in compton
such a long way yeah because his church
is crenshawn right yeah
yeah and and uh he lost he lost he said
he was coaching the guy and he got
killed during the game
yeah so he was like during the game no
during gang violence
oh come on though i don't got shot
during basketball
well i don't know it was dicey yeah yeah
i'll give you guys yeah yeah
yeah well you was talking over there
were you using i wasn't talking about it
i was just like what is it
it was not during gang violence
chappelle yeah gang violence until he
lost him he lost him he said never lose
a kid like that again that's why he
invested oh yeah i remember yeah
and then and then they said he could
coach david like he was coaching
division one he could be a head coach
division one
but the way division one works i mean he
was like i'll never see my family he's
like so i'd rather just be a head coach
at this community college although i
feel like he's doing more like he's
doing a lot like coach k
for duke's not teaching [ __ ] classes
then also the way those kids talk to him
i was telling my girl i played big time
division
one football big time bro if i would
have said
one iota of like those kids talk to him
yeah
dude i would be kicked off the team so
[ __ ] just that one big guy that's a
big guy
he took him out he was like man get me
in the game man any time
uh not joe uh he was the one that played
at penn state and he got hurt and he
kept smoking that's why he was
that kid drives me [ __ ] nuts
he's a ball he's so weak mentally
yeah that he's never but even even after
that i'm [ __ ] up
the tantrums the fouls where he was
kicking the cheers and yeah all that
what's in the locker room he still has a
chance to go division one because he's
so talented but he's
already still careful he can't get it
right he got hurt at the division one
yeah he start smoking yeah yeah and then
that's gonna pass it then how about how
about the point guard the light skin
feller
he's like he's a beast i like it he's a
beast but what's tough to see is he's
16 point guard his his he so his dad was
in his life his dad's black his mom's
super white
his mom three years ago got cancer and
passed away
they were like super close yeah so then
he's just on his own
and he's like he's a team captain he's
the heart of the team he's such a beast
hey
my problem with him not a problem what i
was telling my girl she's like man i
hope he makes it he's not i said the
chances of him making it to
forget the mba that ain't happened but
even
nah that's not happening but well maybe
you don't think you can make division
one be tough dude that's a six two point
guard
but he is still currently right but his
shots are right
uh steph curry six four sir that's the
problem no yeah trust me
he's saying trust me i met him me too
we're eye to eye
i want to meet him bring up how tall
steph curry is i'll help him with his
luggage he's 6'4
but this is the prom with steph curry oh
yeah you talking about the greatest
shooter of all time the nba yeah no
there are guys that are six two of maybe
davidson on the map yeah for sure you
knew that
i did i knew that i followed his career
yeah the problem is my girl is like i
hope he makes it because i want him to
make money be okay
and i was like i know the chance of him
making it is not good
you see how they live on campus i know
oh the way they live on campus
he lives with his girl far he lives uh
all the way out
in uh riverside hike from from where the
school is from riverside it's like an
hour and a half and this girl are cute
though
this is like yeah it's like it's like
just right because it's east l.a
community college
i didn't know this it's a [ __ ] huge
school 35 000 students bro
yeah i know that how many sc is private
so that that one has like eight thousand
ucla i wanna say like yeah maybe ten
thousand maybe let's go to that's like
miami it's not that big of a school
though
forty forty thousand four was there
forty four usc series
or uscla no jesus christ and that's a
private
horrible enrollment every single year or
like in total there's total enrollment
that's 2016. [ __ ] ton for a private
school that's
nuts that's how many different villages
when i went to
uh usc i only stayed with like my
particular college and the theater
school only had maybe like 100 200 kids
oh ucla is a public school and they're
44 000.
that's weird for usc to be private at
44. ucla is harder to get into
depending on the field it is a little
more competitive in certain depending
yeah it depends what you're going into
oh
like their nursing school is very
competitive what about communicating
communication is i think easiest for
both schools
to get into you guys have a better
chance of me because you're black but
that's the white guy
dude that's a white guy
asian dude hey you got a shot let's get
a shot
right you know what if we got you in p
diddy's son uh went to ucla yep
yeah which one my cousin went to the
ucla as well she kept it well
uh shawn did he want to be a promoter
the one that looks like what that looks
really look like
the light skin with the curls oh the
light skin one and the masterpiece son
went to
usually romeo miller yeah he played he
played ball there i didn't understand
his journey because he played ball at uh
usc and then he on commercial promoting
icdc college
oh yeah i remember here's the other
thing
would he
i tried to fight for him because i
thought he was a good player that's what
i'm saying hey yo let's go to my old
alumni game
you know what sad is no one's at the
game how about you teaching that
speaking class he's like all right for
extra credit
anybody go for the game then he points
out girls y'all
you need the credit you're gone she goes
there's more kids at a [ __ ] high
school game not even closer
there's nobody there you see them
meanwhile they're beasts yeah
some of them some of them that i mean
that that east l.a college basketball
team did you see that
but they're like thinking about but
they're you can't get used to a team
they're switching out every two years
yeah so there's no nucleus it's not like
sc or ucla
because they're only in juco they're
only allowed in two years only two years
and then everyone as far as like
everyone they're super selfish too like
their only goal is to get to another
college
yeah they don't give a [ __ ] about the
that's and that's just you know what it
does you know
that's why a coach is so good yeah such
a beast
every two years those kids are cycling
out you gotta redefine the team every
two years every two years
you know what's so crazy i saw that
white guy was shooting dumb number
three's they couldn't stop all right
i was like
dude he was killing him bro you should
be at duke what the [ __ ] are you doing
at jupiter
racing now just every time they couldn't
stop kidding
yes he was a shitty team because they
were like oh they're like the weakest
team in the
world with a bunch of scrubs but he went
off though he went off yeah like
something there's there's always
something going on
i want to know his story how about how
about that one kid kj who's the number
one recruit in
all of california the what's the tall
black guy yeah the baller the super he's
like their best player
yeah and they're like there's no one
liking me six eight he should be there
like he should be
at whatever he is on top of that he
should be at whatever college he wants
to
and then you hear a story and you're
like oh my god there's a reason yeah
he's like yeah my friend you know he's
the number one recruit in
all of cal all of california which is
big time basketball he was as number one
ranked recruit in all of california
he's like and then i just didn't uh pass
the summer class so
i didn't meet the standards to go to
division one like god dawg
which like don't they pretty much you
know you know
they make it easy if you're an
especially friend yeah yeah the easiest
make it easier
if you're our number one recruit oh dude
you literally just have to you had to
show up dude all you have to do is show
up and you'd probably be playing at
notre dame or some [ __ ]
what's wrong with you you
you are jay didn't do juco either right
no
damn no we like real education
teachers are not gonna hate on me for
going to a juco listen
my dad my dad was a uh well it's metro
state i don't think it's a juco
i don't think i think it's a four-year
call but he's a professor at one
my dad was he was yeah oh your dad was a
professor yeah what do you think
business some business is that what made
you want to get a business degree
no i like money oh okay let's say we all
be fair enough
is it a four year yeah he teaches at
denver he still does
no oh he retired that's where he met my
stepmom
uh
metropolitan classes like myself i was
like 30. oh
and i was like 42. got you oh this was a
long time ago yeah
guys not recently that's what they meant
that's
[Applause]
i always love seeing older people on
campus man i'm like man y'all doing my
mom
i was i used to work out at ucla and i
was like godzilla in that [ __ ]
yeah everyone was asian
everyone was the only cla is super easy
oh my god i was like where is it turned
up though it's turned up
super duper asian i didn't know that
yeah i don't like you they call it
university california lots of asians
yep mm-hmm and bro oh i get it i see
what you got
you see a lot of agents lots of videos
and i used to take this my cousin's
lunch cart is
a plethora of asians in the lunch hall
oh they're everywhere oh and they got
their own little diamonds
oh yeah you can use their car uh but you
thought i was at ucla how much i was
going up there
yeah they're dominating yeah dominant
they had to set some sort of like
requirement where they can't have so
many asians now because even harvard was
like all right
enough's enough yeah we need some
whitetails
against asians because there's so many
of us in uh college
because they they they emphasize so much
on education they would
destroy like all that so they're smart
just yeah so i'm left with smarter
what do you mean like their culture
especially when they come to america
really focus on education so
is there anything specific that asians
like to like
study math uh it's a lot of practical
stuff like
uh when i first was going to college my
parents wanted me to become
a pharmacist because they said it's the
easiest way to get into the medical
field without doing a lot of work
because once you have your pharmacy
degree you can open up a pharmacy you
make a lot of money without doing much
so a lot of vietnamese people uh there's
a joke where you're a drug dealer
either you sell it illegally or you
become a pharmacist and there's you
did you tell your parents i have a
different plan i'm gonna start only
fancy
and make as much as that pharmacist yes
absolutely like oh that's
cool the pharmacists make a lot of my
parents they're so proud right now
should make decent amount don't make as
much as cat
really no that's what pharmacists mean
cat makes more than pharmacists a month
are you serious yes i see them on
collaborations all right yeah how much
you guys think pharmacists make i
thought
what's a lot so a year a year's salary
yeah man
no no a week
you're just bringing down something this
is average paycheck to paycheck
hey they're monthly after taxes and the
whole life saving what do you think dude
i don't [ __ ] know it so they get paid
every two weeks
every two weeks what's that not looking
like
i don't know when you started off for
your check
so we're making 140 a year 140 in
california
140 a year that's okay that's a good
payment that's good very good
it's not it's not cash for california
wait
is that what yeah 140 so minus taxes
that'd be like is that good for
california though
dude 140 grand is good wherever you live
oh it is the average person to have more
than 400 dollars in their bank account
i know pharmacists that make like around
300 260
yeah yeah no no illegal actually legal
not really
how they just been they're like in the
upper echelon of pharmacists
oh so you can like move up move up yeah
yeah promotion
got it so where yeah if you want to do
medical like
like if you want to become like a doctor
it's like basically 10 years yeah
and you have a [ __ ] ton of debt and then
here's the other thing so i have kids
right let's say my tiger goes i want to
be a doctor dad yeah
well by the time he's a doctor
technology's going to be
so advanced i don't know if we're going
to need them yeah
we're gonna need them for some things
but as far as like those procedures and
stuff yeah it's gonna be technology
and they're gonna be able to beat stuff
and computerize so i don't
it's almost a waste of time a lot of you
some people did you have a lot of
college debt
no no oh you're
uh i had some debt but i paid it off
yeah i had some scholarships and then my
parents helping
okay so oh so you got scholarships yeah
i had certain i think that's what's
badass about asians and jews is in their
culture they focus so much on education
they just don't know middle eastern any
ethnicity that comes over the states
they're not coming here to play gravas
they're coming into
better africa
oh dude like you meet some ethiopians or
nigerians that was racist you mean some
nigerians or ethiopians they're beasts
yeah yeah oh yes 100 beasts
was she was pretty smart like she i i
i i think it's just like a maybe just a
respect of education yeah that's they
always the household does it's like yeah
it's not that asians are smarter than
any other ethnicity they just focus on
it that's like
in asia that's the only way for you to
really get out of poverty is having an
education that's the only way you get
a job that'll make it and it's also so
highly respected yeah
exactly whereas here it's not really the
same college
i went to college because i could cheer
really yeah did you want to wet unless
you had cheerleading unless i had true
that i would have not went to college
that's the way you're brought up too but
what else is from out college even
like my son got into this school like
when you look at the school in the
curriculum it's like
does this make sense like i guess i want
them learning that [ __ ]
like now with the internet and stuff
they can learn it's like [ __ ] man he's
he's advancing so fast just from youtube
and [ __ ] like like elon musk got a lot
of flack because they went
you know your kids are really smart
everyone says your kids are really smart
and he's like i wish you could take
credit for you guys
they learned most of their stuff off
youtube that's what so think about you
like you went to college do you feel
like you learned complete no
if so let's say tiger unless tiger's
super gifted at sports
i'd be like yeah you're gonna because
when you go to a major division one
college for sports
you're majoring in sports straight up
yeah there's no time for anything else
yeah
so unless he's super gifted i'm like
dude go there to get education
depend on what he wants to do because
the other thing is now we know like you
don't have to go to college to depend
what you want to do exactly you want to
do podcasting you want to be a producer
you want to what do you want to do
you want to be in entertainment like
then college is good for the experience
and life experience but as far as
education unless you're like an engineer
or something yeah i mean
yeah like i i feel like it's like
specific uh [ __ ] you want to major like
if
it's a good it's a good experience
go through some [ __ ] schooling for
that but like certain [ __ ] like
communications you completely wish
you're there you're there to party
bro the kid behind you bro the kid
behind me majored in communications
i'm not even trying to be funny the kid
behind me major in communications
the first day on campus me and him had a
class together and he looked like dead
serious i said he's from louisiana i'm
not going to say his name i don't want
to
adam
good football player he's from louisiana
looked over at me went
hey dog how do you spell chair and i
said and i started laughing at him and i
was like oh
good luck my man and then he's like nah
[ __ ] she was like way bigger than me
he's like
not [ __ ] i spilled chair i was like ch
and then i was like is he for real
he got his degree behind me they're like
brendan schaub and then i was like
i turn around i see him like this
[ __ ] kid he got his degree
louisiana stand up damn yeah that's
[ __ ] crazy that's dope
but what
okay well i learned so much outside of
school
that is like you could use a few more
books i'm not gonna lie to you you could
use a little more life experience
yeah but i didn't kill you i was
learning the order of operations last
night even
operations you they you don't even know
how to do a math equation right
because you know the parentheses that's
the thing about math like now with our
phones and you're like
thank you or writing in general yeah
like straight up right when's that thing
we had to straight up
write some [ __ ] down you remember when
they used to make you uh practice
cursive
because they're all the time yeah now
they don't do it no i thought they only
did it in like private schools
you get to learn curve no
no i'll tell you that i want you to
write a cursive i'm tripping i'm not
going to err
he's like what the [ __ ]
is it hold up you guys got lunch
give me a [ __ ] piece of bread you
want to break it down to break the news
he was like yo japan's like that cursing
for them rich
y'all boozy in here i think i guess i
think i still got it
you're like adam saying spell rizzuto
okay so hold on let me see that's good
it is it is dicey
you don't you don't do it a lot how's
your penmanship i remember my hand you
stole my
mission it's [ __ ] horrible i i have
to like try to oh no
you [ __ ] you write all the time when i
write all of you right all the time yeah
we're on the road he's always up in the
morning
oh journalist yeah you write all the
time yeah
i prefer to write like if i'm writing
bits out like i write bullet points i
prefer to write it out
no i don't like to do on my phone if i
if that's all i have it well but i
prefer to write it out
okay i took the act last night so my
girl last night
went well like an online version of it
no yeah so my girls tutoring
like uh these uh college students that's
helping them for the sat
and she says i want to keep doing that
because it was so much fun this girl was
challenging her i was like hey babe
let's just take the act practice
so i took mine i took hers i i scored a
high number what's your number
[ __ ] what is it 4 30
out of 1600 that's awful
i didn't i didn't finish it it was like
that's so bad it was time so let's
let's just double that score you got a
860 dude
you don't qualify for college which i'm
a hold on but it was a time thing
and yeah i know they all they're all
times yeah so you get a hundred points
for writing your name on the ac
you get a 430. yeah so so we double
that's a that's a 860.
well hold on so just
it was based off what i did how many
questions did you answer uh 120.
how many questions i think i never took
the activities uh california you don't
have to
uh i didn't take act or sat really i
went to community college and
uh by the time i applied they didn't
need me to submit any of those i'll tell
you something order operations
i don't even need that oh so see yeah i
even finished it
i didn't even finish pretty far though
yeah exactly
yeah you got like halfway thank you i
didn't know you i didn't know you could
like you could take
it you could take oh yeah i just
practiced tests online that's why i have
no reason for you too
i don't want to do that order of
operations we should do i might be
disappointed in myself
if i do hey i took i was brave enough to
share 4 30. hey yeah good for you
bro i respect you i didn't finish it it
takes a lot of courage to
shout out to 4 30. i have a zero i
didn't i didn't know
something like that's like me
a lot of courage i was just playing i
got an eight i got an eight
ninety seven that's not good either hey
look at that
chappelle held up today oh yeah right
dog congrats
he's cursive right on dude you're
writing cursing oh that's so bright
that's what do you want me to write
actually you can he could draw that yeah
no i don't want you to write anything
i mean yeah i [ __ ] hope i can write
i didn't know that was so low i wrote
chin there's too much exposure too
bright
there we go i think that's good yeah
that's great yeah that's nice
yeah see it reminds me of my writing
wait but but my writing is not like a
structured writing like you write like i
don't know i just say [ __ ]
yeah but that's what you're supposed to
do when you journal right yeah yes it's
not like i'm going dear diary
yeah which my girlfriend thinks i do all
the time
we got an argument today don't cry
dear diary the word is compromise
[Laughter]
in two minutes girl what the [ __ ]
dear diary i'm scared to eat ass
self-love
that's all i signed
it's just for you sls that's why it's
just for you call yourself
s-a-l-s self-love chappelle
god that's funny damn dawg i'm so hey
when i went to ucla i didn't know what
abc party was until i went there you
know what that is
no tea party you didn't you don't know
what abc party is oh anything but
clothes
bro that was so lit anything but clothes
yeah available
like i came in like a cardboard box you
come in like a trash bag a cardboard box
and just
but anything but it's lit though this is
an encouraging [ __ ] man
every party was just like the toga party
they had to do yeah for what
yeah like throw up in
they had magnums and condoms at the door
so you already know what it is
yeah i see that show you for him like
these kids are lit these bro
it's lit yeah it was so much funnier
than when i was kid i mean yeah they
have crazy depression and social media
bullying but other than that it's pretty
lit it's turned up
what did they have when you was in
school just straight physical bullying
there was no online i'm talking about
partying oh pardon yeah we got we
it was like animal house it was like you
know we had
football but it was like you know the
football team is basically their own
frat so we had
football specific parties was just the
football team after a big game
like we'd get done like playing at texas
a m we'd fly home that night
then especially if we won we'd party
that night especially like we had kegs
keg stands
no cheer parties were lit and then and
then we realized our one friend
who's uh was working for the cartel i
think he's in prison now
he um was would always take it to the
next level
he was like snorting whiskey i remember
one time he like put whiskey up his ass
and when we looked back at it we're like
oh he was so fun and then i think
he had a real problem yeah and he was
crying for help yeah y'all didn't help
him at all hey look at me
put that keg in your ass chris oh we do
edward 40 hands you ever done that
bro dude what's up where are you
we put two mickeys and you can't take it
off till you finish it
are you serious do you get twisted
chappelle you didn't the beer gets you
after you're talking to the booze hound
lacy that's what you're talking about
and you'd be lit afterwards you turned
up i'd be pretty hammering oh i can't uh
i never got into drugs though and i'd
only drink if we i'd only drink after a
game if we won
if you want okay one of the cool we went
a lot those here boys drinking
what was your record that you oh you had
some ballers yeah we were like top
15 for a long time one of the coolest
parties we had was uh we had a rubik's
cube party
so you come in a rubik's cube colors and
[Applause]
dude we get really crazy so what we do
we get a bunch of flaming hot cheetos
and then chapelle figure it out and then
we do a ruby cube
i you like the worst photo yeah that's
me and edward 40 hands i was drunk
is that you it's a whole video that i
don't want to show god who's that nutty
professor taking the picture
some guy cheered with
[Laughter]
no yeah he was a cheerleader he was not
doing
no flips no he was not no he was on the
bottom
[ __ ] he cheered and also played on
the football team yeah same time
at louisville no this is uh that was in
texas yeah
but man look at me i was dude that was
chappelle got a whole hand on his hand
i wouldn't show you the video but it's
like i don't want to get in trouble
what do you mean what i don't know i
just feel like it's i mean i probably
won't get in trouble but it's just
a video of me just being reckless like
kind of reckless retirement here
i was i was i'd love to see it yeah come
on i'll show you i'll show you after
all right okay and then we'll decide are
you ashamed of that
are you ashamed of that i just look at
it and i get anxiety oh
you know but i mean i can't see that way
at all no one can any facet
no one can because it's i mean it was
just i mean [ __ ] when you said
i mean yeah man you just want a drink
yeah you're gonna find an outlet
somewhere
yeah you find an outlet and you find it
through drinking and then these were
wilding out oh i bet that was fun though
but like
like my drinking and anger at the same
time fantastic
fantastic i was trying to fight people
over
anything tell them about the time you
got knocked out when i got knocked out
remember the guy boom the boxing glove
oh he was drunk oh no i remember that
yeah i told him about that yeah i swung
once and dude yeah yeah why do you bring
up that one yeah man
it was a oh now that [ __ ]
knocked me on my ass
[ __ ] man like i i mean i told y'all yeah
i tried to fight a dude over
over a chicken sandwich i mean that was
and that's before popeyes that was
it was before popeye's chicken
sandwiches it was what a burger
i wouldn't find a honey biscuit you want
to fight over a water brush i've never
had it i'd fight over chick-fil-a i'd
fight
everyone in this room overshadowed and
that's fair but chick-fil-a wasn't
really popping
around around the time no was it i know
i'm just saying it's insane
it took him to pop off oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah such a good product yeah
in college oh yeah oh we had him wait in
my
middle school in high school when did
she because what the 1946.
seriously
expensive and only the baller kids got
it okay okay once a month i get it
i didn't on that scholarship when did i
really know about chicken i didn't know
i didn't learn about chick-fil-a until
like
two three years ago the first restaurant
says 1967 so maybe the company opened up
in the 40s something or whatever they've
been lit for a hot second don't you
remember at the mall when i especially
when i was a kid to give out the samples
they were doing this they weren't doing
it you should always get the samples
yeah that's right the marketing move
they give out the samples remember you
like that's the best chicken i've ever
had now they don't even need to get up
no samples
they're like what if you don't they so
nice they're so nice though
oh that's so nice so nice my pleasure
yeah every time my pleasure
when they make a mistake they just put
in remember they made a mistake the
other day when they forgot our
polynesian sauce
it's like oh don't worry about it here's
a whole bag of polynesian and two
brownies because i said oh wow i saw
chappelle he looked like he wanted one
oh wow they saw you am i lying yeah yeah
you did you haven't
either no i did not hear that bro i had
it but again
come on bro i'm checking man listen i
haven't been able to wear this shirt in
a minute
you look good chapel you are yeah you
and brendon excuse me no no kiss my ass
you because when we were in the car he
was like oh
oh pop papa chappelle is in town oh he
already left
oh he left already mm-hmm oh well he
came in just for a day no he uh i had
him
i had him as a guest on my podcast oh
[ __ ] yeah damn
yeah we had a ball and flying gaston
yeah i know
yeah well he bought his hero ticket i
bought his away too that's cool though
but no yeah he uh
yeah because i don't know i was just
thinking about it i was like man you
know we've never really
sat down and had like a long
conversation
and just like we there's so much that we
talked about where we were just so
on the same page really yeah for us not
it's so wild because like for us to
never be around each other
and like i mean it's so this is it's a
young relationship it's only five years
you know because i was 29 when i you
know uh
you know decided to reach out to him but
uh
us to never be around each other we have
so many things
yeah it's crazy like genetics is a
[ __ ]
you guys know you're like exactly the
same and he's a cool ass dude he is a
collection
he's great he you got to see this
picture of him holding my guitar yeah
he's great
he's a fun did you ask him uh i would
ask him like hey man if i didn't reach
out five years ago would have
you have reached out i did ask that what
would he say i did ask that
he he honestly was banking on me never
uh because he felt bad he was like he
goes i [ __ ] up he's probably ashamed
yeah he was probably
yeah he was ashamed he was just like i
don't think he'll ever
you know uh reach out to me it's a heavy
podcast
yeah it was it was heavy it was but it
was great it was it's like
it's heavy but not like uh i'm sure it
helped you yeah it helped
us like it wasn't weird it was good like
it was a therapist it was all
it was like but it wasn't like this sad
thing it was like this
does he own it like yeah i [ __ ] up man
oh yeah yeah oh yeah
and that's and i think that's why oh my
god that's him holding his
dude he says fly outfits
i know he's like color coordinated he
looks great yeah that's him holding my
uh my guitar or whatever
oh man let me hold that because i make
these fools think i could play
but yeah so uh and oh to to answer
everyone's question yeah he was not a
[ __ ]
he was only in blue because that's what
the prison gave them
but then was her blood no he it was
uh i don't know he wasn't a blood he
wasn't a blood
i i didn't even ask that he didn't get
into it
not who because he wasn't really about
the gang life he was just slaying them
it was the drugs he liked because that's
where i mean
you know he didn't make any money like
just gang-banging like
crips you know like crack he was just
like yo like
this is where it's at for me the [ __ ]
sorry interruption
what happened we gotta set up for the
the call wait what did you say wait how
do
you
encrypt my crap too oh that's like
jordan
says republicans by jordan's two i got
it i got it
i'm
i'll make you excited for the miz this
episode of fighter and the kids with the
miz
is brought to you by unleashed with
dingo and danny
a new podcast fueled by monster energy
this summer professional skateboarder
naija houston who's basically michael
jordan of
skateboarding will represent the u.s in
tokyo for skateboarding's olympics debut
but for niger the real skateboard
happens in the streets
put out videos shredding with your
friends being uh in thrasher magazine
that's what it's really all about plus
he keeps a voodoo doll
on his nightstand uh because he's
superstitious
all right or is it just a secret to
success find out
episode one of the podcast as nigel
breaks down raw street skating
and living the life of the world's most
winning street skater
hosted by sports personality the dingo
maybe
uh recognized the dingo off the jason
ellis show he's one of jason ellis's
best friends
and professional skateboarder or sorry
professional snowboarder
danny cass uh unleashed is an
alternative sports podcast you've been
waiting for and it's brought to you by
monster energy
listen man times are tough and worrying
about your student loan payments doesn't
make things
any easier that's where refinancing with
earnest could help
earnest offers low rate student loan
refinancing and you can check your rate
risk free
in just two minutes with earnest you get
to
radically flexible payments and you can
pick your loan term
by refinancing you can reduce your loan
terms save money or combine multiple
loans in
simple monthly payment all right ernest
is offering you guys
100 cash bonus refinance your student
debt
at earnest.com fighter terms conditions
apply
once again you get a hundred dollars
cash bonus when you visit earnest.com
fighter
to refinance your student loan not
available in all states terms conditions
apply
visit earnest.com fighter for more
details terms and conditions apply earn
a student loan refinancing made
by earnest operations llc and mls number
one two zero four nine one seven
california financing law license number
six zero five four seven
eight eight three three second street
suite 401 north san francisco california
94107 in case you were wondering visit
earnest.com
licenses for a full list of licenses
again that's earnest.com
fighter miz what's up brother what's up
miss hey guys how are you
how you doing man you know it's just
another day
i feel you brother i i wish we could do
this in person but
with this pandemic we gotta do zoomy
zoom man
it happens you're uh you you're seeing
your kids mess with the
the set the cameras and stuff how old
are the oh i have uh
yeah i've had a i have like a nice
camera that i use
and they unplugged it and when you
unplug the camera that i was using
when you plug it back in the display
shows on
zoom calls and so you'll see all the
stuff that you don't want to see
and so i have to re-go through and
reconfigure it and everything so it was
a whole problem but uh yeah
the kids getting everything i agree
every time how old
i got two little ones myself how old are
they one and a half and three
oh we're in it dude yeah i got a one one
a half year old and a five-year-old so
it's it's
so funny that everyone always goes we're
in it oh we're in it it's like
yeah it's like when are you not in it
that's that's what i wonder when
when is the the grace period yeah where
you're like
we could sit back breathe take a breath
and just go
ah when's that grace period when they're
30
i don't know because that's what i was
saying like everyone's like yeah when
they're four when they're five like i
don't see it happening when they're four
or five i see a whole new
set of uh obstacles that i will have to
figure out my wife will have to figure
out yeah because they'll go oh get ready
terrible twos i'm like threes are pretty
shitty too man
this is this dude it's an [ __ ] threes
are threes are in there yeah threes are
that's why that's why when i say you're
in it it's like we both went through
navy seals bud camp
you know what i'm saying like only
parents this is chappelle by the way the
other co-host
whatever what's up dude it's it's like
we your
only parents can relate to that you know
what i'm saying when you're funny like
my friends would when i didn't have kids
my friends would be like
you know i'd call them up hey let's go
out and they'd be like dude i got kids
like
you got to stop using that excuse you're
getting real old
now i get the excuse yeah because i use
it on a
daily basis too like and it's no joke
like
people are like yo let's go up my buddy
goes hey you want to go out to eat and i
go what time he goes eight i go
eight eight i'm i'm getting ready for
bed today
that's that dad life man yeah i'm in bed
by nine
i'm up i know my son wakes about 5 30.
i'm not doing [ __ ] outside that man i
can't meet for dinners anymore
nothing dude nothing i saw a picture on
instagram
and uh as a fellow dad you're
inspirational because
uh daddy's getting shredded man you're
in great shape right now
i'm working hard you know it's
wrestlemania season and uh anytime you
have wrestlemania season i always try to
get in my top peak performance shape
uh this is our this i mean we look at
wrestlemania and
you know we see super bowl for nfl mlb
is the world series you know the nba
finals for wwe it's wrestlemania
and it's the greatest spectacle that you
will ever see and
uh you know to get in shape and to make
sure that you are at
your peak level of performance on that
day
it starts back in january so i've lost
about 15 pounds
and i've been eating all the right foods
like i can't wait for wrestlemania to be
over with so i can actually have some
chocolate
and some ice cream because my kids
literally like tease me with it every
day like you know our house is saturated
with junk food yes
and people are like oh you feed your
kids junk food yeah because sometimes
that's all they'll eat
correct yeah my kid has chicken fingers
for every goddamn meal
that's the thing like i see you getting
in shape and as a dad it's tough man
because till your point like
my son has gushers around all the time i
love you don't think i want gushers all
the time
and then he got in trouble all that
stuff i want the cookies
i want the popsicles i want i wanted all
like pizza
oh you don't think i want a piece of
that pizza that you're having right now
i
know throwing on the ground that i have
to clean up oh yes
i definitely do but the problem is like
i can't
and so it's been it's been a it's been a
lot
but uh i can't wait for wrestlemania you
know april 10th and 11th you know we
have two days this
this season and uh and what's cool about
it is i'm going up against
uh bad bunny and damien priest ms and
morrison are and uh
it's gonna be it's gonna be a pretty
interesting match and i think people are
really
ready for it and are gonna tune in and
we're gonna create a moment that's gonna
last a lifetime
i'm just apologizing that i'm gonna
break bad bunny's jaw he's not gonna be
able to you know perform
you know musically for you know the next
couple maybe
maybe a year so i'm taking them out of
the commission that's what i plan on
doing
yeah listen i'll tell you right now if
i'm bad bunny and if you
disgrace my bugatti like you did his the
other day
we're straight up fighting man we're
fighting it's so funny because
you know we had a camera guy there and
we had a couple people like watching
around and
they're like you're not really gonna do
something to that bugatti are you like
it's a 3.6
million dollar car i go oh no
it's it's getting paint on it like that
was real pain and not only that
like my hand was stained for like two
days
like red it was stained red so that was
people were like oh it's ketchup it says
i'm like no
that was real paint and people were like
were you nervous and i was like
no like i wanted to destruct his car i
destructed his car
that was real red paint it stained my
hand for two days and i
honestly it was fun because i finger
paint with my daughter all the time
and usually it's on construction paper
that cost me like 10 cents
i got to finger paint on a 3.6 million
dollar canvas
and sign it with my name it's nuts i
don't think many people get to do that
with guys like bad bunny and floyd
mayweather has done some stuff
and mike tyson so you get these
crossovers and obviously
the wwe fan base is insane man so
obviously everyone wants
you know to captivate a piece of that
audience how do you feel when guys like
bad bunny cross
pollinate and you know obviously you
know what they're doing over there do
you
i i i'll see if they whenever we get
other celebrities from outside worlds
yeah um i enjoy whenever we have sports
stars
uh musicians uh recording artists
uh whatever you whatever you you name it
we've had actors
and any time a celebrity comes in
they're bringing a whole new
audience that gets to appreciate what we
do
on a on a weekly basis we are non-stop
we are live
tv some actors and musicians and sports
stars
they succeed others do not because it's
live it's one take you don't get a bunch
of takes on these sort of situations
and you know with bad bunny where where
i got
involved was i always demand a certain
amount of respect
towards myself and towards this business
and when i first got there
i didn't receive that respect from bad
bunny everybody else seems to uh
get the respect uh besides me so that's
where he
basically you know crossed me the wrong
way
and that's why we're having this match
the problem is with bad bunny is that he
is a huge recording artist there's i
don't think anyone bigger right now in
the music world
than bad bunny i mean he is huge i mean
this guy has over a
billion views not that's not an m that's
a b
on youtube on his music videos you know
people are really into him he's a huge
fan base
i just think that when you step into my
ring
in a wwe ring it's cool to venture it's
cool to come for a performance
that's great but once you overstay your
welcome
you are venturing into my world and in
my world i'm going to
beat respect into you and make sure that
not only that you earn the respect from
me
but you earn the respect from the wwe
universe as well
and that's what's going to happen at
wrestlemania see we could be on it
i don't know if it's for us chappelle
i'm winning i'm ready yeah i think i'm
ready too i respect it though i respect
do you do you get hate from bad bunnies
fans because obviously
you know what you guys are doing you
know
you we know this like there's obviously
an agenda it is a performance
you're an actor to some degree at a very
high level and there's
also obviously risk involved with it but
i'm sure some people
blur the lines and they actually think
you hate bad bunny
that's the art of what we do we have you
know with wwe we look at it like this
watch wwe like you watch a movie like a
tv show
we have amazing storytelling we have bad
guys we have good guys
so get involved with it entertain and we
entertain you and obviously yeah
our job is to blur the lines to where
you're like oh i don't know what to
think because when you go
into a live audience and you're there
and you're cheering for
who you love and booing who you hate
you're invested in that story line
and so that's our job to make you
invested to make you want to see
this match and right now our match is
here
we are ready to go we are primed up and
it is going to be something to
be remembered and i think people like
our job
is for people to take memories that'll
last a lifetime
i have memories as a child watching
you know wwe i want to do that for kids
out there
sure that are that that literally were
my age watching and i want them to have
those memories ingrained in their mind
that i have in mind
so that's kind of what i'm what we're
hoping for and i think we're succeeding
at doing that i agree yeah no i love it
i think i find you interesting and when
they approach to have you on the show
i've been a fan for a while because i
think your journey there's some
similarities between you and i
what i find interesting is i'm sure when
you did the
you you dropped out of college to do you
know the mtv shows
i don't know if you thought you'd be to
this level right like this wwe superstar
and then you have that ultimate kind of
persona on there where you'd call
yourself the miz
and at first i was like yeah whatever
that's fun but where's this gonna go
and this is where it led to and i'm sure
for you you know we have a mutual friend
theo vaughn
theo is one of my best friends and
you know theo is one of the top comics
in the world now i don't know if you
keep up with theo vaughn but literally
when the title i keep up with theo yeah
he is fantastic
and incredible so i'll give you a back
story on theo
uh for anyone that doesn't know who theo
vaughn is uh he was first on road rules
about 20 years ago
uh which was a reality show that was
very wildly popular
and i remember going on a challenge
which is a sister show
of road rules in real world they come
together for the challenge it's a huge
show even right now on mtv
uh so we went on that show together and
i remember theo telling me
i i was like i want to be a wwe
superstar he's like well i want to be a
stand-up comic
and i remember him going to the front of
the bus when we were on the way to go to
the challenge there's 30 of us on there
not many people know each other but i
knew theo
from earlier and he got up on the
microphone and started telling his jokes
and everyone was crying laughing
and this is him just beginning yeah this
is his first start like this is his
first routine that he had
and it was it was god i can't remember
the jokes but it was like
remember when like uh like the the
telephone companies had like dialed down
the middle
yeah and like you know 1 800 then a dial
down the middle and it's like
he would make up these entire jokes
about the telephone companies like
that's how
old how long ago that was
and so now cut to maybe 15 years later
i'm at the improv and i'm taking uh my
wife
to go out on a night on the town and we
go to the improv i'm there
have no idea who is who's playing who's
going to be you know performing that
night
and the main event is theo vaughn
and i i had no idea and i was like oh my
god like
i know this guy like this is incredible
and then
when i watched him perform i i was i was
almost
it was almost an emotion came over me of
how proud i was
of him of where he came from when he
told me
i want to be a stand-up comic to the
level
of comedy that he was displaying like
he was like by far the best performer
there that night
and i was like this guy is ready for the
main stage so afterwards i texted him
and said oh my god i'm in the crowd
how amazing that was in that was in so
we set up and he said i have a stand-up
special coming up on netflix
and then i watched the stand-up special
i was like this guy my god
he had a dream he had a desire he
figured out all the tools that he need
that was necessary
to become the artist he is and now there
he is
at the top of his game one of the best
comedians
out there in my mind my favorite and it
just goes to show that hard work
determination and a goal
when you have something and you said i'm
going to go for it that's what i did
i said i'm gonna gain all these tools
that i need to become a wwe superstar
and that's where my mind is that's where
i'm set up and i'm gonna do it
yeah and it just goes to show even if
you're on a reality show you still
can do it because even though a lot of
times people look at reality shows and
go
whatever your no talent hacks yeah just
live your life on tv but
you know people some people have proved
them wrong yeah you i mean you and theo
are the
the example of that when i text theo
you're coming on the show
he said i love i love that dude he saved
my life one time from some house
he was absolutely loved the miz and i
you know with theo
he doesn't he he's gonna hate me even
talking about this but [ __ ] it
he um you know he doesn't talk a lot
about his mtv days he doesn't like to
address it stuff like that
because he's in such a diff different
lane now and he's
he's known for that he doesn't like to
ever look back in the past
did you feel like it was hard for you to
shed that label with the mtv and the
reality show stuff like that like
did people think i was there like there
was a time
in my career so the reason where he is
saying
and i think this i think i understand
where theo is coming from
so back in the day when we were on
reality shows there was only a couple
a couple available like real world road
rules uh
big brother uh survivor there was a
handful of them now
it's a dime a dozen hell instagram's a
reality show if you want
tic tocs is a reality show if you want
but back then
back when we were on we we couldn't get
into a room to audition for anything
yeah they looked at us as no talent
hacks
and that that we were just on a reality
show and that's all we could do
is just be on a reality show and we
couldn't do anything else and we would
never amount to anything
so when you're putting the passion and
trust me i have never said
a bad thing about what is mtv or buda
murray because i've always been very
grateful
sure for being on the real world for
being on the challenges because
it set me up and it gave me a whole
different mind frame
that if i believe in myself that i could
do something i
could pursue something different than
what was supposed to happen and
in where i was from parma ohio you're
supposed to go to college after college
you go back to part of ohio after you go
to parma ohio you
you get a family you get a job and
that's what you do for the rest of your
life
but being on the real world it set me
off and said i
know i could i could be a wwe superstar
even though they're six
seven full of muscle and
and and charisma and and they're larger
than life
i could do this if i set my mind to it
and so where i think i have been able to
say you know what
screw it i don't care what anyone else
thinks of
you know if i'm on a reality show or not
like there's paths
and nowadays i say do it all
yep like my agent will ask me like what
do you want and i go i want it all
and he goes what do you mean by that i
want reality i want hosting
i want movies i want wwe i want
it all everything give it to me because
i want to show
that i have the talent in whatever i'm
doing
to be able to succeed at it and so give
it to me
and so now my my my agent has done a
tremendous job
in getting me all these different things
and all these different opportunities
like i get to do ms and misses which is
our reality show about my family
inside the life of like what it is like
to be a wwe superstar
and be a dad of two beautiful daughters
and be a husband to a wife who's also in
wwe
and we made a comedy show like literally
i look at our show
it's a reality show it's based on us
absolutely but i look at it like the
office
i look at it like curb your enthusiasm
like seinfeld and people are like oh my
god you're looking at it like the
greatest show ever yeah yeah
i am yeah and i'm proud of it it's a
show that i think people will watch with
their families and go and laugh
and enjoy and you know with wwe i'm
doing
the best work i think i've ever done in
wwe
because now i have a mindset that i can
do anything
i can do it all and i'm not going to sit
there and say i'm not going to choose
this lane
like they asked me to do the challenge
all-stars and
i was i won't do a challenge again
because i don't want
i don't want the drama but i wouldn't
mind
hosting it or doing a guest host spot
because
i always want to pay tribute to where i
started yeah and who gave me my
opportunity and that is mtv and buna
murray
and the real world good for you well i
when i always think about you like even
from those
you know earlier days i think everything
you've always done
has just been so authentic and it seems
like
you know when you trans transition from
mtv to wwe
like it didn't it like i never saw it as
like this weird thing like what the
hell's he doing he's this guy from
you know real world or whatever why is
he trying to do wrestling i always
thought it was like
oh [ __ ] yeah he's doing it and it just
it just seems like you've always just
been
authentic and true to like like like
you've been saying like yeah if i want
to do it
i'm to do it you know so i think it's
been cool to like not see
not apologizing for it either yeah just
doing exactly what i want to do because
i believe what i'm doing could make a
difference in in something like as
stupid as a reality show is like it's a
reality show about something but guess
what there's meaning there's issues that
we tackle
that i think a lot of families are
dealing with that sometimes especially
in a time like we are right now with all
the drama in the world
i think it's some i think it goes to
show that we need things on
tv that literally you can just set your
set all the pressures that you're having
with your day
sit down with your family and just laugh
and relax and enjoy
and i think we need that in television
well yeah
look just looking at the result of
everything you do like it's like this
guy
really does believe it like he really
does
feel it and that's yeah and i don't know
i just think that's like cool because
like you could easily not
you know like yeah most people wouldn't
take wouldn't be able to transition from
the mtv
uh reality world and be able to jump to
something that they really want
yeah to do to that point too i think ms
is like i'm sure when you told
your family and friends you're going to
go into the wwe
and i'm sure fans that were you know
around then were like dude what are you
doing that's stupid you know because
i think for a lot of people like you
switching lanes for them doesn't
doesn't make sense like no those guys
have been wrestling since they were kids
you know so i think a lot of them like
you you always say stay in your lane
it's like well no i like a bunch of
lanes man
you can that's your that's your you're
pushing that agenda on me i don't want
to be in that lane i want to be in this
lane this lane in this lane
everyone's always gonna tell you you
can't do something and the reason they
sometimes tell you that
is because they can't do it they can't
see themselves doing it
it doesn't mean that you have to listen
to that person as a matter of fact i
listen to those people
i hear them and i use it as fuel for my
fire
to say hey i want to prove them wrong
but not only do i want to prove them
wrong i want to make sure that they know
that
when i succeed at it if they have a
dream
they can do it as well yeah and so and
maybe they'll turn that negativity into
positivity and that's where
i kind of i stem everything in my life
from is like i try to
generate positive and people are like
but you're a villain on tv it's like
yeah but i'm a villain
who when the good guy beats me everyone
celebrates and everybody is happy
and it it always has it coming i know
you know
in wwe the villain's going to have it
coming sometime or another someone's
going to give it to him
and you're going to have a reaction a
celebration like
the coolest thing you can have as a wwe
superstar is when you have a title
i had i just had the wwe championship
the most coveted title
in all of wwe i had it for eight days
i went up against bobby lashley that's
my guy
right now is on fire
how big of a freak is bobby lashley oh
my god you know i used to train with
bobby
i used to train with bobby and you know
he has legit like credential wrestling
background
in the military and when we would
wrestle
i never saw him get taken down once ever
in training ever upon muscle like he has
a six-pack and then he has a six-pack on
top of that six-pack that's how
jacked and big this guy is but not only
that tiny head
let's say he's a very hard worker very
dedicated to the craft
and it's taken he's never held the wwe
championship
even though we everyone's always known
he's going to get it sometime or another
and then he went away from wwe and then
he came back
and he set the world on fire and when i
lost the wwe
championship even though we were two bad
guys
people were celebrating bobby lashley's
reign as a wwe championship for the
first time i remember
going backstage in gorilla and everyone
applauding
and literally saying congratulations you
deserve it and to me
i was proud because i was like wow like
we did that in a matter of eight days
yep we built this
this program where people were really
looking at it and then
here's the repercussions everyone's like
oh you only had it for eight days
oh you only have yeah anytime you have
the wwe championship
if it's for eight days uh if it's for a
day
if it's for a minute if it's for a
second you are
the wwe champion and you will always
have that
yeah so eight days as long as you
do what is necessary for the company and
wwe to succeed
to build another superstar which we did
we
built bobby lashley into this huge
monster
and now he has a huge match against drew
mcintyre
who by the way through the out the
entire pandemic with no fans only
virtual fans which wwe has done a
tremendous job of
has been able to carry the wwe
championship for most of that
and has done a terrific so these two
titans are going to go head-to-head at
wrestlemania
and i was able to be a part of that
story
to build these two characters to where
they are going
in a prime time main event wrestlemania
caliber match
so i'm proud of the work that i've done
and i hope
that they are proud of the work that
they're done because i can't wait to see
the match at wrestlemania yeah i think
it's interesting the
out of all the major sports leagues the
only ones who really did it right and
had success during the pandemic was the
wwe
and the ufc you know yeah i mean wwe has
done
a tremendous job in making sure that
each and every week
you know the fans have something live to
watch
when baseball was gone nba was gone
football was gone all sports were gone
we were still there
trying to entertain an audience because
in in the most
critical time that they need it yes and
i felt safe doing it
yep respect respect man
well miss we've i've wanted you on the
show for a while man like i said i'm a
big fan you're you're a
motivational guy and it's hard to get me
motivated man not a lot of people
motivate me i love
i love your story man i really do you
make me want to stand up for you guys
i really appreciate you guys taking the
time to have me on your show
yeah um it's an honor and privilege so
keep up the good work
and uh please if you talk to theo before
i do tell him i said hello and then we
talk great things about him because
he truly is uh one of those people that
i don't think sometimes he gets enough
credit yeah he's especially
one of the best stand-ups out there
agree agree man well appreciate you miss
good luck
uh april 10th and 11th good luck brother
no need for luck when you're this good
baby
all right brother have a good one man
i like his energy man you can talk right
yeah have you have you ever worked with
wwe guys before no i've never had
when they're like like he's known for
like his charisma and his smarts they
can
talk well have you ever seen john cena
in like an interview or like the rock
they're like beast dude beast i mean
they're like real seasoned actors and
like
yeah hype men so notice we didn't have
to talk much there yeah
he'll go he'll go it's hard to get in
yeah he'll go you have to pick your
spots but it's so unique about him
because he was the first wrestler
to have a talk show during wwe and
interview
like different wrestlers he had this
talk show called the miss
so i was like inside of wrestling it was
so oh yeah they said it was inside the
ring
without the ring and like you it would
be a break it's a segment and the miz
will come and interview another wrestler
and then of course he'll probably hit
him and he acts like hard hitting
questions
like like i'm a like i'm a fan of like i
don't
watch the wwe i'm not a huge fan of
i'm not you respect it's you i respect
what they do and it's a tough [ __ ]
gig
but like i can't get into the you know
how he's like i'm gonna hurt the bad
bunny like
i can't i can't play that game uh-huh
it's like when he's doing that
like i'm gonna [ __ ] him all right i'm
gonna break his jaw i'm like oh man
so it's it's awkward for me yeah yeah
yeah
because i gotta go after this and break
down you know ufc 262. you know like
you know what i'm saying so like i'm i'm
gonna hurt the bad bunny it's like
no you're not wait back to that brother
that
uh bobby bobby that was my guy yeah
bobby's a
good friend that is he's my training
partner for a long time
tall no six two maybe six three best
wrestler nah kurt angle was the best
wrestler but i think that uh he's second
best
and like as far as like wwe his bet his
bad
credential guys what his background was
real wrestling real
in the army and then yeah he was in the
army yeah damn but then bobby lasher was
a real pro mma fighter yeah he fought
over in japan he fought in bellator
okay yeah oh [ __ ] i didn't know that
tiny head
i know i saw that so in relation to his
body
he was such a beast man no one could
take him down he was saying his head
yeah exactly that's what i'm talking
about yeah tiny hood
yeah this is interesting dude i like him
i like yeah i've always liked to miss
man
he he said we can do wrestling b
god damn i don't want to do it man three
a tag team match
us you need to you have to get on
steroids
if it was you and i you'd be the
skinniest guy ever to grasp no i'll be
right mysterio you know what you know
ray's jack no but he's he's one what
he's short
but once jackson does flips and [ __ ] off
the ring i can do it
have you have you seen me on the
trampoline i'll do the flips now like
you know who we look like we would look
like carl winslow
and steve urkel oh
no it's not oh god bro
they have a tough gig too man they're on
the road like 300 every year
yeah like i talked to one wwe diva
that's not that's the bass brothers yeah
that's the way they are that's them
can wear your sex mask and everything i
know perfect
you want to block out all that
confidence
now yeah a lot of those guys are
motivationless [ __ ] man john cena
the rock like those boys but you have to
be a personality to stand out in the
wrestling
aspect because you're gonna be good on
the mic like those promos they ripped
they're sure
the rock got so good at being i used to
play that i used to play this
smackdown game that was just skill you
have to be
a personality on a mic to win fans
yeah because i created my playing video
game no because you create your play you
gotta go through like
the journey to get to the www i'm trying
to think who else
oh uh david uh batista oh
yeah he's huge oh you know john cena is
in the new suicide squad movie oh dude
really
he's he's done he's got a swimmer too oh
yeah
he's on wwe uh wipeout i'm gonna say www
uh no he's a host of them
what abc oh is he really i don't know
that he's
but he he got a lot thinner too yeah
he has a weird build something's off
what do you mean
he's just so he does look weird right
there he looks jacked no he's jacked no
doubt
but his butt something's off on his body
i don't know what it is
does he have a short toes torso i think
it's the shoulders
he's so big though and strong look at
that [ __ ]
god damn insane is that a snake
they're all really good dudes too like
yeah you talked to stone cold steve
austin i've done his show we've had
i think he was on the first big brown
very big no well yeah the big brown
breakdown was called
he was the first guest one of the first
guests i heard he's like he's just like
one of these great
give me a hell yeah great guy yep that's
one of the slogans
uh great guy i like how you try to
get the voice it's terrible
okay that's what he did thank you so
much i'm gonna go
current events
so khloe kardashian's assistant
accidentally uploaded
a uh photo onto her instagram account
and she quickly took it down khloe
kardashian is currently in the process
of getting people to take this photo
down and sending out like season
decisions it belongs to the streets
yeah it belongs to the streets now
what's wrong with the photo it's just
not edited
like she looks perfectly fine she's in
great shape but it's not as edited as
the stuff that she usually puts out
she's madness it's natural i think she's
that's just like her brand she likes
having being in super control of what
she looks like and
the one that posted it her sister
accidentally did and she's mad because
she wanted a filter so she looks like
yeah
everything she and her sister's post are
super heavily edited and so she didn't
want like a natural photo of her being
out
she's great i think she looks great
think about what crazy world they're in
where if they post a real picture she
freaks out sending season to sis
it's their brand [ __ ] that's how you
look
and she looks great but that she looks
definitely better on the right yeah
and that's the but she looks great on
the filter on the right yeah
yeah this filter yeah what kind of
filter like a tanning
no it's probably one of those like uh no
probably paris
paris is the one that lightens and
smooths their oh yeah
i was thinking of hudson as well it
could be a hudson but yeah you kind of
filter everything out so everything
looks
generally kind of soft and hazy oh yeah
i mean she looks
great it's a great photo but yeah she
gets uh called out a lot for using
photoshop do you remember we talked
about the before and after photos of
like what she looked like on the reality
show
versus like the it's like yeah i don't
know it's the real person
it's a it's insane oh you've never seen
the book chloe in the day
you're seeing chloe back in the day did
not look like that
i think kylie's the biggest come up yeah
absolutely
no everything no she [ __ ]
did her jaw line her chin or nose
this was the one that looked the
craziest but that but that's not even
no no no she hasn't just faced this no
no no no no
go down to the one that no no no no down
chin
that one that's what she used to look
like
she like bubba sparks
she's a big girl yeah that her on the
right she don't even look like that
she that's completely filtered and
messed with
she doesn't even look like that's a
different person yeah she'll look bad on
the list that's what a lot of people are
saying because this is a clip
on the right is from the reality show
it's like her confessional section
of the show and then the left is what
she posted on instagram because she has
a filter on
it yeah
you imagine all of the graphics that we
have just chappelle's super skinny i
don't know what i'm saying
is super skinny and alex he's buff
that's
why people see us in person oh god damn
man what happened my dad was like man
you know one thing i noticed about that
picture with you mike tyson
you're way bigger than him i'm like bro
you're a bigger i've been arguing about
this all over the week yeah
it's all good though so the rapper
cam'ron
actually went on social media and made a
video talking about how he has over two
hundred thousand
people blocked on instagram why he says
at least
if they just say anything he blocks them
so this is the video video
i love cameron oh he's a did he still
rock the pink let me tell you what i'm
saying about black he looks
every minute i got at least minimum two
hundred thousand some people block
minimum that's at least maybe more than
that
don't ever feel bad about blocking
someone
paige it's your [ __ ] sometimes people
are too opinionated on your [ __ ]
you get what i'm saying so you got
social media
whatever platform it is snapchat
instagram
house somebody come in your house and be
like
i don't like your curtains
[Laughter]
i don't really like the furniture go get
the [ __ ] out
bro i respect that so get the [ __ ] out
give a [ __ ] i'll block a [ __ ] i
don't give a damn
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't care
you're not going to come to me that's a
healthy mindset he says he talked to
himself every morning
for like 10 minutes he was like i went
hollywood before
i was hollywood he was like ooh you that
[ __ ]
that's what he was like
it's on revoked noriega's podcast yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's a big podcast it's a
great yeah and he was recently on there
talking just like this like just
positive but he's been the same dude
200k blocked i mean that's something and
that's his estimate
that's probably more than that he
200k at minimal yeah like well all black
people if they talk [ __ ] about my friend
even it's not about me talking about
brian chris you guys they get blocked
blocked it's so easy but he was dating
his girl juju and a lot of people was
like man she looked to look good for you
underneath the comments every time
oh yeah i'm loving that yeah oh my god
people hey why don't i get blood that's
my favorite thing
it's like don't because here's the thing
the thing is
when people talk [ __ ] to you even if
they are joking yeah look
i don't know you yeah like if you came
on my page and say some [ __ ] like
yeah i know i know you yeah but these
people i don't know so you talking to me
as if you know me yeah and i don't want
that energy i don't want that energy
because i don't know
and i'm not gonna know if you never post
i don't know who you i don't know how
you're
i can't gauge you because i don't know
yeah you're the one that loses out on
this
you're the one that's the fan yeah cause
cause though sometimes like oh i was
just joking and i'm like
but i don't know you that's like you
can't joke with me because like
the funniest dm's i get is tell brittany
unblock me no
yo yeah no i'm about to block you
but now i gotta
okay so pete davidson has finally moved
out of his mother's basement
into his own place that headline's
hilarious congrats congratulations
27 year old multi-millionaire pete
davison finally moving out of his mouth
hey listen that basement was decked out
that basement was decked out i was hey
talking about it uh he was on
like some sort of uh zoom interview and
randomly during it he took out his keys
and uh
opened up a door and said that he
actually moved out recently of his mom's
place
i guess someone tried uh breaking into
it too but he was gone already
yeah someone broke in his mom's house oh
that's something you know yeah
people people you know watch are you
good what you know watch it are you
really worth watching it's just a small
clip of him saying that he moved out i'm
fully out i got a pad
that's hilarious there you go good for
him shouts out
kanye west has sold the rights to
his life documentary to netflix for 30
million dollars
he's had a team follow him around for 21
years and record things that they've uh
kept in a vault that they've never
released and so he sold all that footage
for 21 years yeah 21 years of content
so this is like through the wire kanye
his president
ron kanye kardashian post kardashian
kanye i'd watch that
yeah taylor swift [ __ ] taylor swift
stuff rick raw stuff
i wonder if he can release uh taylor
swift's stuff because there was a
lawsuit about um
you can't record a phone call without
the other people
not like knowing that was the weird
thing yeah
one of her legal issues that's what he's
going to say didn't he catch her in a
lie
uh that i don't know about that because
yeah well if it's according to what kim
posted so it's him talking to her
and him telling her that he was going to
have her on the song she's like no
that's cool that sounds cool
the problem is is he didn't say you can
call her a [ __ ] he didn't tell her what
he was going to say
so she okayed on it he was like okay i
refer to the song so make sure you're
okay with she's like yeah i'm cool
she's like you never said he's gonna say
[ __ ] he didn't play it for
no oh that's kind of awesome you know
i'm writing this new song and
i reference you you know i got nothing
but love she's like you know that's cool
it's an honor
but it's him being like yeah you [ __ ]
hey i got number
one it was it was i made that [ __ ]
famous yes
oh yeah she was already popping before
he did that
yeah but 1999 2009 no no
that's the name of the album taylor
swift oh that's what you're talking
[Music]
so she wasn't popping back then i mean
she was hot
when he went up on stage and did that
[ __ ] yeah hip-hop world though she was
like a lot of people i came over
i didn't know her i came over to support
her
um are you swifty i mean she won she
wanted
grammy not but not before that no it was
it was an mtv award
for our best music video yeah and that's
why he was like the best i remember that
[ __ ] happened that she was
she's she's been [ __ ] big man she's
been big for a while
but to your point i do think like that
made it in the
like grand scheme of things people who
didn't listen to the country yes
it gave her more clouts but then she was
already famous before that she had her
own
i'm sorry hey i'm sorry okay i
definitely didn't hurt her i don't know
how to take it
definitely didn't hurt her yeah it hurt
and nobody talks about uh afterwards
beyonce actually won an award and
instead of doing it uh she let taylor
swift get back on stage and say her
acceptance speech because kanye said
that's cool nobody talked about i
remember taylor swift's face it was just
so like
she was on oh do you see how awkward
that is the best is when kanye west is
doing that public service announcement
with mike myers
oh he said george bush
he seemed to slowly drift away though i
remember like
yesterday i was watching one of the
funniest videos he's like we need your
money
i know yeah kanye
george bush doesn't like black people
mike might say okay i'm out of here
what else you got jen all right uh you
guys mentioned paul pierce
and sources close to both parties said
that he was let go by espn because of
that post
thank you that's what i'm hearing he was
like go previous to that yeah
he posted that video because he knew he
was no longer in a relationship with him
oh so
he's not stupid that's him celebrating
oh that's what people
people think he did it to be you know
just like he's free
and like he also posts before that like
big news coming and
you know i got stuff in the works he
posted that i don't know if it's
because of that or because he was
already
out of contract at 409 this guy sports i
guess
reporter or whatever at 409 he said that
yeah they parted ways effective
immediately and then
4 23 paul pierce big things coming
and then that night
and then dave portnoy hit up paul pierce
oh yeah he'll have a show with them for
sure
yeah she's good for portland man we
can't we couldn't tolerate that lebron
hate on national tv paul pierce
uh well this is good news apparently
june 15th is the date that
la's supposed to reopen yes and
including
already pretty lit i thought they said
yeah yeah i think it's been popped but
even like a full
wait so let me illustrate what even if
i'm vaccinated i still have to wear a
mask
how stupid is this are you are you
getting a vaccine
i don't know no but but wait wait so
again so if they force us to
travel yet but i've had the virus a
couple of people who got the vaccine
they have paperwork and yeah your
paperwork so i was at a restaurant last
night and
they asked him the guy to put on a mask
he was like no i have paperwork
and then he showed her the paperwork and
he like can i be saying this on camera i
don't care how are you gonna say the
place and they let them in without a
mask or anything is that what they call
that vaccine passport is that what it is
yeah that's what it is yeah uh
your vaccine card you used to have to
bring it uh when you were in high school
to
prove that you didn't have like the
whooping cough i did oh jesus
it's really against the rights of
americans to to
require a vaccine passport don't get me
started on that i know but i mean the
whole thing is like you don't have to
come in the
establishment if you don't want to wear
a mask yeah yeah so they could be like
just eat your businesses
but in texas like they made it so it's a
rule where you can't enforce math and
they can still go in your place of
business
which is how it should be in california
we're nowhere near that no okay i was by
that uh the channels were two masks
i was buying that korean barbecue spot
what was it called brothers
quarters quarter quarters i was about
quarters yeah you're right
it's popping over there
it was popping over there it's clean
everyone's having fun
yeah the koreans are doing it right
there's like
they're even closer together outside
than they were inside it's ridiculous
for everybody the spot i went to because
quarters was super packed i went to
101 i don't know what it was no it's
right now was it good
yeah it was good korean barbecue yeah it
was good
but uh people people were walking in
without even
having a map that's what i'm saying i
saw that last night oh i said their name
i hope i think it's okay i think we're
at a point where it's fine
okay yeah yeah yeah okay and speaking of
disneyland is supposed to open up
this month end of this month 15 capacity
and you have to make reservations
it's gonna be a beast i i can't imagine
even getting a reservation
disneyland no meet and greets no meet
and greets what are you doing
what being
here's my thing but why not meet the
characters they're in the [ __ ]
outside
that's what i'm saying they already have
the mask thank you everyone take my
niece what do you mean i don't i can't
have any money oh i thought this was
like you
like your personality
it's going to be tough though because
it's it's shorter lines not
many people i wonder how tough it's
going to be to get a reservation i know
no you could get one no
if you can get one i feel
please hook me up as well i'm the only
one with kids so please hook me up
i got a niece no you don't care my girl
loves it you guys too old it's for kids
you know
you ever been as a grown person lately
yeah it's interesting
yeah your girl loves it yeah you you
hate it
yeah i don't [ __ ] with that [ __ ] it's
tough it's a long it's a lie
it's a grown adult then all also like
the music like likes
it can't last longer like when they have
like a person that like really guides
you on every
ride you're talking about the vip thing
yeah uh
depends you don't do oh that's the best
you ever hear a club 33
oh you're not in it nobody's in it i
don't know
no one in here isn't it i've been there
you haven't been thirty three
it's three three three right three
through three or thirty three i've been
in there
you've been in are you sure it's like a
milestone
you can get in there some you know
somebody knows someone yeah we knew
someone that knew someone and we had our
whole table too is it fantastic in there
it's pretty dope it's like going on like
a
like a nice las vegas place where you
can get whatever you want tell me buffet
wow it's pretty cool they don't have
pictures of it online i'm sure you could
probably
right that's what i thought yeah you're
not supposed to do anything pretty dope
so you have to know someone to get in
there yeah
someone connected to you such a long day
dude when you're walking around
but it's the best everyone's out a
magical kingdom yeah i'm different
and then when you're home you sleep well
it's cool you sleep really well in the
house
because you're walking nine [ __ ]
miles it's the best the rides are the
things that [ __ ] me up though you don't
like the rides
i just don't know that cars ride is lit
i can't laugh
cars are so good i can't i can't do real
roller coasters at like six flags
the x2 is different x2 i guess i'm too
old for it i think
i get super nice i'm sick now oh my god
the dream i used to love them
see i i was never really i've always
loved them me and stevie and jay went
when we're in san antonio didn't you
guys get sick after two rides
we bought all these vip passes which we
didn't need because nobody was there
we were on two roller coasters and we
look at each other like should we get
out of here
i gave some family our vip passes that's
cool
damn uh i didn't know this kind of was
like swept under the rug but one
championship today
with mighty mouse and eddie alvarez
they're on food truck
yeah so it's today is it 10 p.m eastern
7 p.m pacific on tnt that uh i think tnt
in asia
i'm not hunting no it's on regular teams
all right it's just a big deal it's
their uh north american debut well there
you go it's a big deal yeah
yeah so that's something to look forward
to tonight that'd be dope okay um
all right that's it perfect yeah that's
it man
shout out to the miz shout out around
wwe april
10th and 11th i love the miz pretty
motivating dude
you watch this tv show it's pretty great
yeah yes sir it's so funny i'll check it
out
um naples next week april 15th to the
17th that's naples florida
we out there probably on jet skis you'll
see our thick asses cruise around the
water avoiding charts
and chappelle going real slow and then
austin texas all shows are damn near
sold out so we're going to probably add
a late show thursday so april 22nd
through april 24th
vulcan gas company austin texas we
coming baby
special guests will be there as well
we're gonna have a grand old time and
then just announce houston texas may
20th through the 22nd
houston texas and then chappelle lacy
is at a good night's comedy club may
13th through the 15th
those tickets are on sale right now
chapelle lacey.com being
it's in north carolina did i say that
nope what did i say good night
comedy club and no one knows where
that's at i didn't say north carolina
i thought i said that i didn't like my
last episode did i not say it i don't
think so
i'm with you well north carolina i'll be
in raleigh you say good night's like it
was the comedy store in l.a i know right
yeah i'm sorry
sorry sorry raleigh north carolina i'm
sure it's a great club
yeah i hear it's good no i can't go see
chappelle man yeah
all right kids love you you really do
look like you're about to go fishing
yeah bro yeah i know you know you caught
my neck
oh mally b rolly boy that's disgusting
what do you say
that's you gotta rhyme man you got
around like my uncle would say
you know oh trevor scott travis scott's
pink laces yeah i got them from my man
justin
awesome
this is boring shoe cam intro
walk through whatever what's up man i'm
chapelle lacy i'm a big fan of sonic
youth and this is my favorite sonic
youth album
washing machine okay and today i decided
to wear
my jordans with this sonic youth t-shirt
because guess what else
i haven't been able to wear this t-shirt
in a minute and you know what you lose
since i've been losing weight what's
that good dude baby
you know what i'm saying that's due this
morning didn't see you but you're
probably gonna go later i'm
guessing as i always do
from suplex yeah but i want to shout out
them nope okay
next week naples florida then the week
after
april 22nd april 20th 22nd austin texas
oh may 13th through the 15th
good night
shout out brendan shout out holy face
i will see you friday